we have a tweet from Eric swalwell and
this might be one of the funniest bits
I've ever seen this makes Saturday
Saturday Night Live look like you know
amateur improv hour at a local local
College Comedy Club Maga Republicans
want women arrested for having an
abortion this is what that looks like
all right let's play the video it's got
2.5 million views as of as of 24 hours
ago I hope you guys are ready to enjoy
this oh wait I gotta fix the audio I
always do that because before the show
we switched the output yeah all right
there it is there it is
he is weird but cute
Rose
Mary Anderson yes I have a warrant for
your arrest a rest for what penal code
243 violation unlawful termination of a
pregnancy you've got to be kidding me
that that is my personal business that's
for the courts to decide man your
medical records have been subpoenaed and
Dr Landry's already in custody
oh my God you you can't just you will
have to submit to a physical examination
no no no one's touching him
turn around put your hand behind your
back now why is this happening
love you honeybear
we're just enforcing the law here
elections have consequences no Democrat
on November 8th stop Republicans from
criminalizing abortion everywhere
there's more protect women's rights and
freedom
please don't do this
Eric swalwell you know what I love like
in the beginning when he's doing like
near the baby's mouth and then the the
wife is like he's cute and the kid's
like he's gross I was thinking like
the reason why they can't get the acting
right on what a family looks like is
because these people don't have families
yeah so they're just like I think this
is what it looks like I also want to
point out that the first reply you can
see is from Adrian Curry shout out
people cannot afford food gas or even
their own homes and this is your
strategy LOL no seriously like the
production value is so bad yo the cops
if they ever did show would be like man
we have we have a a warrant for your
arrests
come with me they wouldn't be like
you're going to get a medical exam we've
arrested your doctor they wouldn't say
any of those things until you've got to
remain silent anything is here to do can
be against you the court of law please
put your hands behind your back and that
would be it and everyone the husband
would be like oh well they're going on
and then she'd get arrested that's about
it would you be arresting people
yeah well I look at it like okay there's
a little baby right there uh eating uh
and what if they what if they decided
they were going to kill that little baby
then wouldn't it be just well that's her
personal business well yeah yeah I guess
that between them too right like you
know but that that to me that's how I I
view it and you know the more I look
into abortion and the more I look into
really what it is uh it is murdering
babies that's what it is and so uh yeah
it should be uh it should be enforced do
you think from the point of conception
at any point abortion should be made
illegal penalty prison I do believe I
believe that life begins at conception I
believe that that is the correct
a point in which you would you you would
determinate a life and then that the
state's job is to protect it should the
mother go to prison as well as the
doctor like in this video from Eric
swallow uh yeah uh it's a it's a sad
unfortunate thing and it's going to be
very difficult to try to get like
Society to switch their minds on this
that that it's not okay to kill a baby
um and it's going to be hard uh I think
we've got to be a somewhat uh you know
I hate saying this but you know there's
a transition that you have to you have
to go through but it is not okay to kill
babies I mean if you like the contrast
of this I guess because this really
isn't a great production but just go and
watch I mean it's terrible to watch but
just go watch a video of an abortion you
I know what you need to do you need to
make your own version of this but like
the mom has like a mustache she's
twirling I'm gonna kill this raming and
then the the husband's like yes uh so
but no I mean if that's the case
um a lot of conservatives say they would
never go as far as arresting the mother
for this it's the provider who kills the
baby who would be punished not the
mother but you're saying you you think
the mother is involved well I mean if if
Justice was to be served it's those who
had the intent to kill
what about exceptions do you think there
should be exceptions so I think
conception should be termed because
there is the where you have
um
where the baby gets or the the uh gets
in the uh excuse me I'm trying to get in
the Philippian tube and that topic
pregnancies yeah there you go that's the
term uh and that will kill a mother but
I think those are considered non-viable
as it is and so those aren't at least
for a long time that wasn't considered
an abortion and then in vitro is another
thing like you know because they're
actually taking the the sperm and the
Egg out and they're uh
fertilizing it if you will and then
they're putting it and so some people
are like well that's conceptionist too
so I think that it needs to be deter or
as part of the definition must be that
it's in the womb there there's
challenges here because I understand
what you're saying and uh Eileen more in
the traditional pro-choice side the
issue I take with it I also view is a
Libertarian perspective in that
it there are circumstances there's
challenges here I'll admit so let me let
me walk through this there are
circumstances where
if a woman does have a legitimate risk
or problem with the pregnancy how do you
get through that effectively does the
state have to get involved and issue a
permit to allow it to happen I mean
these things can become overwhelmingly
complicated and then what what is an
actual Health matter for the mother is
now an issue of the state and
certification or permitting and stuff
like that I I have a I have a hard I
have an issue with that well so I do
understand though just to just a walk
through this I think abortion is wrong I
think too many women today are using it
as contraception I think the mainstream
left the modern left is pro-abortion and
that makes there's there's there's no
there's no middle ground for you know
how we actually deal with an extremely
complicated and let's let's be real
there's there is no middle ground I mean
you either are going to create a
circumstance where women will get
elective abortions as birth control even
though we think it's wrong or you'll
penalize the woman or arrest the doctor
or the woman so and that's why I you
know I intend on declaring life begins
at conception and making that the point
because ultimately it's
it's a determination of when life begins
because
then you have to say well
then it's not okay to take the life
right I mean if life begins at this
point then it's not okay to take the
life is it you know we all agree that
after the baby is born it's not okay to
take their life right well I don't
believe that that's when life begins I
believe that it begins at conception and
so therefore the state's job is to
protect that life and uh and ultimately
when it comes down to like a court
proceeding or or a trial or prosecution
it comes down to intent what about in
the case of rape
so
I actually I'll admit to you that I did
at one time believe that that should be
an exception uh but I do not believe
that there is a right way to take a life
I I hear what you're saying I and I I
understand the moral position the
challenge I have in this circumstance
let me pause first because you know
people get content get heated on this
one
um
uh well let me just say we'll get
through this we'll get through it we'll
get through a woman who through no fault
of her own is raped and forced into
carrying a baby
she did not she was completely
responsible in every right and was
victimized I don't see how the state can
determine that you have to provide your
body to another living person now I I do
understand this is the extreme it is
extremely rare that this is the case in
terms of abortion this is the problem I
have 90 was it 92 percent of abortion is
elective or no no reason give it just
just contraception concept of abortions
that that's that to me is insane
but the issue I run into is the
government being like now I know you
were victimized but we the state have
determined your body and blood now must
be shared with another person so this is
the reality of it though
um the reality of it is is
those who get an abortion suffer more
emotionally in many other ways because
they got an abortion versus those who
actually keep the baby they may turn
they may give it up for adoption
whatever but but they are I mean they're
healed more by having going through that
pregnancy and having that baby it's it's
difficult yeah but that's that's not
that's that's not a legal more or or
moral argument I mean that that I can't
unders I can't understand that argument
I mean if there's a woman who says you
will not the government will not force
me to carry my rapist child like
you might think she'd be better off but
if she's saying if she's gonna kill
herself again I know the writer that
it's writer that that child to to live
that's that's where that's where that's
where it becomes it's difficult right
because we're talking about a life here
yeah that's why we're saying that just
because of the circumstance that you
were you know if you you were
uh created if you will uh now because of
that circumstance we're going to take
your life and that I just don't I don't
agree with that I think that the the
better way is to to side with life
that's where I that's where I end up
Sheamus uh coglin of Freedom Tunes made
the point I believe it this was the
point you made Sheamus so if I'm wrong
uh uh forgive me but uh he said the
detriment to the female in the scenario
is less than the detriment to taking the
life yeah so so his point was basically
yeah you know you know what this woman
might now have to suffer for for another
nine months but suffering for nine
months is not nearly as bad as killing
determinating the life of another being
I I still run into this I don't like
government and I and I don't like that
idea but but I certainly understand uh
believe me I'm I'm right there with you
and I it's tough huh but man when you
when you watch which is terrible I've
never been able to watch a video to the
end with it
person I can't I can't
um well and so then then that's what
changed my mind that's what that's what
changed my mind if a woman has a
miscarriage should there be you think
there should be an investigation no
that's a natural thing that happens but
what if she like jumps on the ground and
kills the baby because then calls it a
miscarriage if there was intent that's
what all crimes are based upon intent
like like if you intentionally tried to
kill the baby you know then then the
state would probably have some
jurisdiction there but
you know like how would they know unless
they investigate yeah but it's just like
any other crime how do you know unless
you investigate I mean and they just
don't invest we're just not we're not
talking about like talk about precedent
we're not talking about uh creating an
entire system with all these exceptions
and everything we're talking about we
already have murder laws we already have
these laws and they're based upon intent
and basically saying that life begins at
conception and so the state's duty is to
protect that life well not all life you
kill mosquitoes um but you're talking
about yeah humans or people persons um
and the argument is living tissue isn't
necessarily a person so like a sperm
isn't a person an egg isn't a person a
spermig combo isn't necessarily a person
until I in my opinion until it's
thinking and has feelings and emotions
and has a a sense of self
um other than that it's just like
growing tissue yeah but with that I
agree I agree uh that's the argument of
like when life begins right
um but I mean I I you know I've had I
have six children and a newborn you know
is is not very aware of themselves not
not when life begins Life Begins sperm
is alive eggs are alive it's always
living stuff but whether or not it's a
person whether or not it's murder
depends on if it's a person because if
you kill a cow you're not murdering it
well it consumption conception is where
you know the the sperm and the egg come
together and they begin to grow as a as
a as one if you will and I believe that
that's when life begins as far as I mean
I get I I I get but I don't want to get
into somatics you know yeah I think life
began it's already it's always living
yeah
but it's not about killing life I just
want to say you know personally I'm
pro-life but I'm extremely skeptical of
giving police officers more reasons to
arrest people how would you handle it as
as a governor what would be a punishment
like what would you do to to a woman
well we already have murder laws right
you know so that's life that's that's a
Life Center no not always
no predominantly depending on the
severity of the of the charge the degree
there's there's third degree I think
there's even fourth degree in some
states right and and the laws you know
the laws are there for a as a deterrent
right I mean you know uh
there that's really what they're there
for they're they're a deterrent and so
uh this would be a deterrent for people
uh taking the problem is if you don't
enforce laws no one takes them seriously
and it wouldn't just be a deterrent if
you're enforcing well I think there's a
there's actually a much simpler uh
breakdown of what happens the end result
is a abortion clinics just cease to
exist the the overall the amount of
abortions that happen will drop to a
ridiculous ridiculously low amount
they'll still happen the state probably
won't be arresting and Prosecuting
doctors because they'll be done in
secret and there's a lot of problems
with that the left brings up but in
reality as much as the left wants to
create the scenario where like the
police show up and they're like your
doctor's been arrested that probably
will never happen extremely rare
something that people need to understand
is that people can go online and admit
to committing serious crimes and post
the evidence and the government still
doesn't go after them the reality to
this life to this country is that they
do not want you in jail they I mean
first of all we all know it's going out
with the woke left in these big cities
releasing people like crazy but there's
overcrowding the courts don't want to
deal with it I can't look I once got
arrested for skateboarding and the judge
was pissed I show up for court and he
and he puts his glass on he looks and
he's like what he said come on my dock
is full already and you get out of my
courtroom so what what really happens
with these laws is my prediction on if
they actually did criminalize abortion
Nationwide as as like a murder charge
Planned Parenthood clinics just cease to
exist and it would not be that big of an
issue but you'd see miscarriages Spike
well I think I don't I don't think so a
lot I really don't think so oh yeah I
think I think babies
are shift everyone's going to stop
having sex like it's not a big deal it's
going to be a very very different thing
from the ground up just make one law and
that'll change right I think we'll
realize okay it will have a massive
impact I mean look at uh there are
questions about when uh what can make
culture shaft for one the entire of this
this country just all of a sudden
decided that the the marijuana laws
didn't matter and people were just going
about breaking the law making movies
about how funny it was so I'm not
convinced outright the culture would
change but Planned Parenthood and
abortion clinics would cease to exist
overnight if there was a nationwide ban
yeah and of course many of the left and
pro-choice they freak out about that
idea that's a reality there will still
be there it's not going to be back
alleys with coat hangers it's going to
be private underground facilities
the people who send stuff in the mail
little pills you take it there's no
trace of it there's gonna be a huge
spike in miscarriage no there's not are
they just going to pretend like they're
not doing Secret abortions when they're
having and what you misunderstand is a
spike in miscarriages requires women to
report the miscarriages are happening
yeah so if you unreported stuff so if
you mean women so miscarriage won't
Spike because women will be inducing
abortion and not telling anybody so
abortions will go down some abortions
will remain miscarriages won't because
women are not going to report their
their their illegal abortions how is
that stopping the ethics of killing the
baby that doesn't change that one is the
state's not paying for it and two is
there is a law there in in place it is
it's a moral thing it stops elective
abortion I mean it it stops the
overwhelming majority of elective
abortions
a lot of that stuff is safer than taking
pills and killing them okay but hold on
look look you're getting me to argue for
him now
or the miscarriages would spike is like
I mean think okay let me let me walk you
through this again a woman who has an
end who induces an abortion illegally
would not report it right I don't know I
don't know she would go to the cops and
be like I broke the law arrest me is it
known that she's pregnant do her
neighbors know they're like you know she
was pregnant a week ago how would they
know whisper whisper if you're and then
the government's like we'll pay you know
we're making up scenarios it's important
to note here Dave Portnoy is going to be
really pissed if this goes through and
then number two he's like what you know
a lot of people will go to Canada and to
Mexico like already a lot of Mexicans a
lot like a lot of Americans are already
going for for their health care as well
so that's another component so the
interesting thing is is on the other
side of this I want to completely
deregulate them the medical uh industry
uh interesting and uh but why is
abortion different because it's life and
if there was one thing that the state is
supposed to do it is supposed to protect
life and so I'm you know I I lean very
heavily on the libertarian side
absolutely so this is not with abortion
I think it's an argument uh Ben Shapiro
was made as well that if if God if if
you're libertarian and you believe in
very limited government there is one
thing that most people believe
government should do and it's protect
life that's right but then it's the war
machine like it's the killer
government's main job is to protect life
but it's also to kill and to make murder
legal so that they can kill that's not
something Libertarians agree with my
point is making the government's
function Libertarians are like the
government should protect life not not
be actively taking it and most
Libertarians I think overwhelming
majority are anti-war and don't want the
US involved in The Killing and and
Industrial military industrial complex
I'm raising my hand for that I mean
absolutely yeah so like if the
government's going to protect the life
of a baby by destroying the life of a
mother I just don't see the protection
we got to stop right there the point
that I brought up that shape that I
reiterated for Sheamus is the mother
will live and the baby will live or the
baby dies and the mother will live you
see you see the issue you're talking
about like no abortion versus abortion
right in an abortion someone dies
someone lives with no abortion the
mother suffers for a an extended period
assuming the mother is suffering and
then the baby is born but both live
that's that's the moral argument that
Sheamus made to me I'm not saying I
agree I think the idea that more life is
better is kind of erroneous too because
it's quality of life is super important
yeah I guess so yeah but you don't take
life just because you're not going to
have good quality that's that's not
justification to take I'll just I'll
just shout out Sheamus again he made a
cartoon where there's a poor kid sitting
on his bed and he's like malnourished
and everything's grainy and gross and
Democrat Man shows up and then he's like
help Democrat man I'm hungry and poor
and he goes I'll save you and then
disappears and then reappears instantly
and then he goes what did you do when he
went he goes I went back 12 years to
convince your mother to get an abortion
and then the kid goes what no and then
just disappears thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to Tim cast.com or tune in Monday
through Friday at 8pm and we'll see you
all there